hi it's matthew martin from details and
earlier today we saw the louis vuitton
collection by kim jones and it was
amazing it was all about the himalayas
and mount everest basically he gave us a
unbelievably chic expedition collection
and i love that he really took a lot of
things literally and there were these
beautiful shearling jackets that were
hooded he paired them with great knits
there was wonderful suiting there was
beautiful boots it was all about the
expedition but keeping within the
vuitton parameters of ultra luxury and
ultra sheepiness in addition to
shearling coats there were these really
gorgeous shearling bags that actually
have a dual functionality and i think on
the runway they showed them as more of
like a structured bag but actually we
were fortunate enough to get a preview
and all of those bags you can open up
and make more of a casual tote another
interesting passage were all these
beautiful felted coats there was a
blazer and a couple of top coats and
felt is wonderful because it's very
light but it's incredibly warm he closed
the show with all these really wonderful
prints by the chapman brothers there was
beautiful evening jackets and there was
a pair of pajamas and there was even
more of an embroidered bag it sort of
fit the whole theme of the show
perfectly and i love those you know kim
jones always gives good show and today
was no different and it's just really
easy to be able to take each look in
each piece and be able to say oh i want
that or this is what works for me
because you know it's so relatable even
though it's just crazy fantastical ultra
luxe gorgeous like adventure that he
took us on today if you're late to this
party go to details.com for more videos
from paris and also you can check me out
on instagram and twitter at details